what are you doing what are you doing oh
he's trying to get over see that was my
fault I like this person I like how this
person is driving before it even turns
green they're already pulling up they're
ready to go I judge their parents on how
they react to the light you should be
like Big Daddy Don Garlits as soon as
that tree turns green man you stand on
it son go you [ __ ] go go not yet
oh that would have been disastrous don't
listen to me but he has on a sweater and
a nice hat that's a love story you can
watch a woman underneath an overpass and
she's still captivated by your every
word that's a love story that actually
warms my heart
chances are go go go here you go good
move good move good move all right now
we're on the we're on the highway every
place else in the world the further left
you are on the highway the faster you're
supposed to be going you're not supposed
to pass on the right but every [ __ ] out
here that's exactly what they do so when
you're trying to get off you got to go
like [ __ ] 90 miles an hour come on let
me let me in this person you're gonna
let me in you do should see my [ __ ]
turn signal thank you
even when never do she's still wave
stops them from taking the gun out of
their [ __ ] glove box now look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] giant green bus all the
way over on the left what are you doing
except slowing people down this is like
the Manson Family bus what are you doing
what are you doing oh he's trying to get
over see that was my [ __ ]
and I'm passed on the right I'm so full
of [ __ ]
that was bad and the guy was black
somebody thought it was yelling
something racist I mean the whole fan
don't and I'm wearing like the [ __ ]
like I feel like this is a classic
racist white guy sweater you know what I
mean you just look like you're ready to
take a family photo and then you say
like the most horrible things ever
alright welcome to the neighborhood
I'll tell you they gotta build that wall
they got to build that [ __ ] wall man
what do I do I get in front of the van
and get from the van man you get in
front of the van and watch this I cut in
front of this [ __ ] guy but I do the
wave thank you thank you
ruthlessly [ __ ] texting looking right
down I said she's either trimming her
[ __ ] pubes or she's texting and I'm
watching her text so I'm part of the
problem and I would say something but in
today's climate I would probably get
busted for some sort of harassment hey
here's a thing too when you're in this
traffic follow you know safely behind
but don't be that douche that leaves
like 20 [ __ ] car lengths like you're
trying to prove some philosophical point
you know like hey man like it's like ten
people get in front of me I mean I'll
only get there nine seconds later so
like where's the hassle that's when you
wish you had like some sort of [ __ ]
thing that you didn't care about on the
front of your car what did he call those
things those things they had TJ Hooker
you just slam and it won't repeatedly
this is where you just start getting
close to fall but he just wants to
[ __ ] slamming into people
all right can I get over can I get over
please thank you Sunday was when the
traffic is really [ __ ] bad I
fantasize about living on top of that
Hill right over there where there's no
other houses and just having a zip line
right to where I go to work right into
my [ __ ] office of course I'd have to
walk home right
but getting to work would be awesome I
hate seeing all this litter on the side
of the road they ought to give you the
opt-out like what do you want to do you
want to do jury duty or do you want to
pick up litter you just have to do it on
one little [ __ ] this ship without
depressing that is what are you throwing
all this [ __ ] out there you clean it up
Christ chick clean it up what kind of a
[ __ ] animal just drives down the road
and throws this [ __ ] out okay so how are
you raised you know it's funny you're
not really throwing your trash out
properly are you you're just putting it
in there taking it away to throw it
again outside someplace else that we
don't have to see it right they throw it
out where all the porpoises are out
there in the ocean
that's true I was actually looking up
the history of garbage the other day was
this whole long article and I was just
like this is too long for me to read
this I was gonna change my behavior but
now I'm not look at this some rich guys
building a [ __ ] skateboard ramp for
his kid he's gonna have that giant truck
full write-up and have illegal
immigrants under the age of 8 lifting
all of that out there and you think
that'll be reported of course not but
you know what I mean Matt Lauer comes
sashay in in with his junk out of his
pants and all of a sudden that's a story
I mean where's the justice
having said that sexual predators need
to be eradicated out of our society
I just want to roll my window down and
talk to these people stick where are you
going
the way the [ __ ] my god I'm not going
anywhere I'm driving around out here to
talk about how bad the traffic is so I
guess I'm hoarse